AI這麽多
但口袋這麽淺
你真的知道訂閱哪一家的AI CP值才最高嗎
今天我們這集影片就來跟大家殘酷的分析比較ChatGPT Gemini Claude Grok
哪一家的模型才是最值得我們掏出錢包訂閱下去的服務
嗨各位又是我AJ
不曉得各位平常都有用什麽付費版的AI呢
過去這一年里面我們最常聽到的問題就是 AJ 你把每個AI都講得很好
但是我一個月就只有600多塊錢的扣搭
我究竟應該買哪一家服務你比較推薦
這個問題呢
這是個大哉問
因為過去每家AI功能都不太一樣
所以當時蠻好列出區別 but到了2025年的下半年
現在每一家AI功能越來越齊全
很多功能都會互相重覆較勁
今天我們就來帶大家剖析 究竟四大AI的基礎付費版
也就是GPT Plus
Gemini Advanced
claude Pro還有Super Grok這幾個到底是誰才是最值得我們訂閱的AI服務
就讓我們馬上開始吧
好 現在 暫停 截圖
然後按讚訂閱分享
這就是我們比較出來的4家AI殘忍的大比較
我們直接看這張四大AI的完整比較表
你可以清楚的看到ChatGPT plus、Google Gemini Advanced
Claude Pro 還有 Grok 的 SuperGrok四個方案月租費大約落在20美金上下
除了Grok比較任性一點是30美金之外呢
表格里面我們整理了幾個最關鍵的指標
包括主要的模型 最大上下文長度
是否能聯網搜集資料
支援哪些檔案跟多模態的功能
影像跟影片的生成功能 以及有沒有自動化或者是代理人等等的特色
這張表的目的
是希望大家能夠不用逐一查資料
就能夠一次掌握這4大AI功能在規格上的差異
那麽接下來我們來看看這4大AI的各種特色說明
那我們先從大家最熟悉的ChatGPT開始講起這個方案呢
一個月20美金 大概600塊台幣
那這個方案就是你直接用上最新的GPT5
說白一點呢
文字生成的效果依然是目前市面上最穩的 還支援多模態
文字 圖片 還是語音都能夠一次搞定
那在功能面上 它很像是一個辦公百寶袋我們可以丟PDF
丟Excel丟CSV 然後丟程式碼檔案給他做分析
還能用不同的模式
比如說學習模式 陪你複習功課 思考模式陪你拆解問題
畫布模式 用視覺化整理資料
網頁搜尋模式直接幫你抓最新資料
再加上task功能
能夠幫你排成提醒還能透過連接器去串Gmail
Google日立 GitHub等等
儼然就是一個小助理的升級版 那另外ChatGPT Plus還有幾個招牌特色
例如說制定GPTS 你可以打造自己的專屬應用
甚至你可以只開放給團隊的同事使用
不過這個方案也有GPT的Team團隊版
Agent 模式可以讓AI能夠去幫你做網頁的點擊 填表單
自動寄信
自動訂餐廳 這部分雖然說還在逐步開放出來
但是聽起來就像把動手做這些事交給AI
另外還有記憶的功能
會記住你常用的需求
配合project的資料夾工具
長期的專案或者是數據處理也不成問題
當然他有一些加分項
比如說圖片生成功能 能讓你快速的生成或者是編輯圖片
比如說GPT image 1模型好用啊
AI吉卜力之亂 高峰期的時候伺服器 就會給你優先權
反應比較快
進階的語音模式啊
可以讓你用講的就跟GPT流暢溝通
不過呢 也是有一些缺點比如說功能有一些分層
比如說進階的API或是一些Agent的模式
只有到Pro或是team才能完整的取用
再來如果是plus用戶在尖峰時段你還是有可能遇到速率的限制
另外大型的文件處理也不是它的強項
你一次丟幾百頁的檔案去 他就跟你說不行太大了或是讀到一半直接斷掉
再來他的搜尋功能預設是用 Bing 的搜尋引擎
所以如果你的網站上的SEO只有放在Google的搜尋引擎里面
那你有可能會找不到
另外Sora影片生成的額度實在是太低了
而且它真的超級難控制
實用性我覺得不太好 那另外程式生成的功能雖然說比過去的GPT好很多
但我們自己測下來
我覺得還是輸給Claude或者是Gemini
整體來說呢
ChatGPT plus就像是一個全功能的入門款AI
它的定位就是功能多
更新快 適合大部分的人
如果你只要寫文件啦
開會做筆記啦 快速分析資料 它其實非常非常的夠用
可是如果你要跑一些長篇的研究
寫程式
大規模的生圖 生影片
那你可能就要找其他AI工具啦
接下來我們來看Google的當家花旦Gemini Advanced這個方案
在 Google one 里面的AI Pro方案月費是19.99塊美金
差不多也是台幣600塊到650塊左右
他現在主打的模型是叫做Gemini 2.5 flash 跟Pro的模型一個是比較速度快的
一個是比較思考久一點的
那就等於給你一個快刀跟一個重炮各一把
在功能面上Gemini的多模態能力非常的完整
文字圖片
程式碼 表格 各種各式各樣的這些資料他基本上都能夠吞下去
還能夠直接分析文件啦
試算表啦
Google Drive里面這些資料啊
甚至是整本PDF
另外他的deep research功能
輸入一個問題他就能夠整合Google全網的搜尋的結果變成一份報告
在進一步轉成Canvas畫布模式變成資訊圖表甚至是測驗題
還能夠去串Google的Gemini的API
實用性非常非常的高
它的特色功能除了Deep research之外還有Veo3這個短影片生成的這個工具
還有GEM和這個客製的小AI聊天機器人工具
最近最引人注目的當然就是Gemini最新推出的圖像生成新模型NanoBanana
雖然說這個名字聽起來蠻可愛的
但是它的威力可是都不小
它在細節
速度真實感 說實話都明顯壓過ChatGPT的
GPT image 1
GPT image 1唯一個勝的就是
他的中文字生成勉強還可以打一下 剩下我覺得都已經輸給Google這個模型了
優勢的部分不用多說
因為這是Google自家的模型
所以這個模型會整合到Gmail
Google文件
Google 日曆的Google meet
Google Drive 而且如果你訂閱這個AI方案 還送了2TB的雲端空間
在Gemini處理長內容上面是目前業界最強最穩定的搭配Google雲端伺服器的可靠度
然後去使用比如說NotebookLM的一個服務 你幾乎不用擔心斷線
對研究生 上班族來說這就是一個全天候的研究助理
缺點還是要有啊
很明顯的一件事情就是他有一些地區限制
就好比說你現在用Google meet的時候他的中文會議摘要功能還沒有支援哦
他只能做英文的會議摘要
所以這東西就是
你只要等他慢慢開放
另外他的語音
跟GPT的那些voice的這個語音模型比起來還是比較不那麽自然
那Veo3的影片生成品質說實話還可以哦
跟Sora差不多
但是他的額度其實也沒有很高 就算付費一天也只有三支
最後一個這是Google的
我覺得是他原生比較尷尬問題
就是Google的Gemini可以分兩種方案去買
第一種是用個人的Gmail去加購這個AI的方案
另外一種是在公司的work space方案里面去加購GeminiAI
這兩個方案是不一樣的
而且功能也不一樣哦
那有些功能這邊有
有些功能那邊有啊\
就是這個東西
我覺得他在產品定位的時候其實還有一點點的混亂
最後跨語言的資源跟資料庫的架構存取方面也有進步的空間
總結來說 Gemini的這個advanced方案就像是研究生跟上班族的夢幻神隊友
如果你們的公司沒有採購Google的這個workspace方案的話
我還是蠻強烈建議你個人可以去採購Google的這個Gemini Advanced這個方案
他擅長處理大量的資料
能夠幫你生成各種各式各樣的形式的報告
因為他跟Google的生態做了緊密的結合
如果你工作跟學習基本上都在Gmail里面 Google文件里面 打交道的話呢
這個投資絕對是立刻回本
第三個是 Claude Pro
Claude是由Anthropic公司推出的產品
然後他的月費一樣是20美金
也大約600塊台幣左右
他現在最新的主力模型是Claude sonnet 4.1
這一代的模型特別強大
在長文處理跟邏輯嚴謹上的表現
Claude最有名的就是他號稱所謂叫做憲法級AI
他特別擅長處理論文 法律文本
研究報告 這類嚴謹邏輯的內容
你也可以上傳PDF
上傳word
上傳文字檔
請他幫你做長篇的摘要
說實話他的文字的量不如Google Gemini的NotebookLM
但是Google Gemini NotebookLM可能會幻覺
Claude這邊呢
他產生幻覺的幾率 就我自己的心得來說
他發生幻覺的幾率是相對低一點的
另外Claude還有另外一個非常強大的功能
就是在去生成程式碼
不管是解釋程式碼 加注解幫你做生成
寫Python 寫SQL
寫VBA 寫GAS
這些東西基本上Claude都可以處理的非常非常的好
那最近他們有出一個叫做Claude CLI的功能
那這個東西就是你可以在類似命令提示資源的模式之下
讓這個Claude的AI Agent真正的成為你的一個寫程式的一個好助手
簡單來說我覺得他是這四大AI里面的理工法學院的高材生
他特別擅長處理嚴謹文本的這些分析
另外就是擅長處理程式碼的生成
另外Claude Pro還有幾個特別值得一提的功能
比如說Claude project可以把多份資料跟對話
集中在一個專案里面 方便長期追蹤
這個ChatGPT也有 而Google就沒有啦
Claude code可以進一步提供各式各樣的SUB agent
讓AI自己去呼叫8個10個小AI去組成一個小型的開發團隊
加上他一貫的嚴謹風格
比其他AI更少胡亂編造的AI幻覺
所以這是為什麽在學術法務或者是系統開發大家都非常非常喜歡用它
對於用量大的用戶呢
Claude除了Pro方案之外它還有Max方案
Max方案它提供5倍Pro方案的用量到20倍Pro的用量 等於是升級版的火力支援
一個月雖然說要付到可能8,000塊
但是我目前我看到有網友是一天可以把那個20倍的Max方案的額度
用好用滿哦
那等於就是你
手上可能有100個人的小隊在幫你做開發
這真的是非常非常的強大
額外的優勢方面
Anthropic強調他們在訓練的時候強調3個h的訓練框架helpful
honest還有harmless
讓輸出的內容更安全
更少偏頗的內容
另外它也可以透過程式碼去生成SVG格式的資訊圖表
這對於你要輸出可視化的內容的時候非常非常的方便
我也還蠻喜歡用它去生成SVG的這些資訊圖表
另外Anthropic還推出了一個叫做MCP的協定
它可以去把模型跟服務去做一些連接
就有點像是ChatGPT的Connector
或者你可以把它想象成像是一個AI的外掛
讓Claude有機會能夠連接所有的服務
另外Claude還有跟Canva合作推出Ccode的那這個功能我們這有拍一支影片啊
如果你還沒有看過的話你可以直接看一下
最後你可能會覺得說Anthropic 這間公司到哪里來的小公司他會不會倒掉好
但是你如果去查
你會發現 Anthropic 它的最大投資方是Amazon貝佐斯的亞馬遜
後面有AWS後端資源
我覺得Claude的後勢相當可期
但Claude Pro也不是沒有缺點
他每日的訊息限額大概是45條
每5個小時會重置一次
所以我自己有時候卯起來用的時候
我大概在兩個小時之內就會用到他的上限額度
然後就告訴我說哦你要再等3個小時之後還有一個倒數計時器
然後呢你才能夠繼續使用下去
對重度使用者來說
我覺得Claude可能還是得買到Max那個方案 可是Max那個方案就比較貴一點
另外就是Claude Pro缺乏內建的圖像生成的模式
所以他只能用程式碼的方式去生成SVG這種相對簡單的圖形
最後 他的界面目前還是英文版的啊
所以如果你對英文不是那麽的習慣的朋友來說呢
我覺得使用起來還是有點壓力
就會有點不舒服
總結來說Claude Pro就像一個邏輯嚴謹的研究助理或者是邏輯嚴謹的中階工程師
如果你的工作是寫研究報告
處理法律文件
做專案管理還有程式開發
他能夠提供你最穩定的支持
那如果你期待的是比較花俏的圖像生成或者是影片生成
或者是聲音生成的功能
Claude就不會是你的優先選擇
最後一個壓軸登場
是Elon Musk他們家的Grok
Grok的付費方案叫做Super Grok
它的定價稍微貴了一點
一個月大概要30塊美金
換算著台幣差不多是900多塊快1,000塊啦
比其他三家貴了快5成
算是這四大AI里面高價位的選擇
他最近推出了最新的Grog 4模型
支援聊天問答 程式碼甚至各種各樣基本功能 多模態方面
它能夠處理文字跟圖片
它也能理解表格
它最突出的地方在於即時聯網能力
那件live search他可以直接抓最新的資料
因為他跟Twitter是同一個集團的
所以他也可以直接進去Twitter里面去抓到這些即時的推文
幫你生成回覆甚至直接做成梗圖
這完全就是社群玩家的愛用神器
特色功能里面 Grok有幾個很狂的地方
像是think mode 它可以快速切換問題模式或者深度思考模式
另外它的deep search還有另外一個叫做Deeper search的功能
就是他可以去切換你的deep research
這個功能在操作的時候要花多少的資源多少的時間
定位上跟Google Gemini的deep research非常非常的像啊
但是我覺得他能夠找到的資料是Google找不到的
那當然Google能找到的資料 他通常也都找到
再來就是它最新的Imagen的功能
它可以不限量快速的生成圖片
另外它還可以把圖片按一下直接轉成影片
還有另外一個號稱辛辣模式的特效
整個就是娛樂屬性還有18禁屬性拉好拉滿
另外手機APP里面還有一個功能叫做伴侶模式
里面有一個非常非常有名的AI伴侶就是Ani
基本上就是把這AI當成是一個社群陪伴工具在做
另外還有一個額外的優勢就是
不要忘記馬斯克還有另外一間很有名的公司叫做特斯拉
所以Grok除了能夠去跟X 推特去綁定之外呢
現在在北美已經內建到特斯拉的汽車里面去了
所以未來像Cyber truck或者Tesla Bot
或者是你自己的特斯拉搞不好系統更新完之後呢
你就可以像以前的霹靂遊俠一樣
跟以前的早期的這個科幻影集一樣
你能夠直接在車上跟你的汽車AI去做聊天
甚至你可能可以直接對你的車子去下一些工作指令
當然他的語言風格上非常非常的活潑
不是其他三家能比的
他對網絡梗的反應程度
還有他嘴賤的程度 這都是Grok我覺得非常非常有趣的地方
不過Grok的缺點其實也非常的明顯
首先它的價格說實話是比較貴一點的
訂閱成本直接比其他的AI高出一節
另外他在工作生態系上面明顯不足
比如說你要在office里面你就不可能用Grok
你只能用微軟的Copilot
你在Google work space里面你只能用Gemini你沒辦法用Grok
所以差了一個辦公應用整合的這樣的一個剛性的需求
你要怎麽樣鄉村包圍城市
我覺得這個是Grok未來幾年非常重要的一個工作
另外Grok很多新功能優先都只會給英語系國家哦
所以其他語言的開發速度還有支援速度說實話明顯慢一拍
總結來說呢
Grok的這個super Grok比較像是一個社群娛樂神器
如果你是迷音玩家
Twitter重度用戶 甚至是未來的特斯拉車主
這款AI絕對能夠玩出花
如果你是研究生工程師或者是每天你跟報告文件奮戰的上班族
那這筆900塊的投資 可能就沒有前面三個來的划算
最後我們來下個結論吧
說實話我覺得如果你是創意工作者的話
ChatGPT還是首選
沒有什麽好說的
花下去就對了
那如果你是個碼農
你是工程師 那Claude
你一定要認真用 卯起來用
然後最好把自己用到max乘以20那個方案非常非常值得投資
如果你是學生
當然如果你的學校有採購Gemini的教育版進入到Google Workspace里面
當然那就是免費可以使用的
不用白不用
但如果你真的想要花錢的話
ChatGPT我也是建議各位
畢竟出社會很多工作都會需要
你還是要稍微摸索一下
最後就是老師
現在所有的老師啊
除非你正在用Apple iPad家的這個系統去做相關的工作
要不然的話 Gemini應該是你的唯一的選擇也是首選
另外Grok我這邊特別要提一嘴
就是我們之前在上課的時候有遇過一個有趣的情境
就是剛好有學員說我們在做燒燙傷相關的議題
我想要請AI生成臉上有傷疤的圖片
不管是GPT然後各種各樣的AI模型
基本上他都沒有辦法生成有傷疤的這種圖片
那這個時候Grok他沒有底線的圖像生成的功能 應該就會是你的好幫手啦
以上就是我們這一集的內容 希望對你有幫助
那如果你還有朋友還沒有聽過這些AI工具的話
馬上把這些影片分享給他
那我們下次影片再見嘍拜拜